I've been doing that with fried chicken
eating it every day like there's like a
good two week period I was having it
almost every day
from where
ver you're in some random town
it's like we could be a little healthy
I'm like
what about chicken with bread around it
this reminds me of something okay all
right can I show you this of course okay
so one of my favorite oh all right words
so what's the accent phallic plants what
the heck is up with that
so so 10 plants you can suck off
okay with that damn see that plant you
splooged on that plant yeah
God damn you saw the way he gripped at
in the beginning
dude do me next
so what's my one of my favorite
um
like genres of food content is like
Southern Pit Boss okay you know like
big dudes from the south that smoke meat
and they make ribs and like just
southern comfort food
so my friend sent me this dude
and he's awesome but we gotta I think
together figure out how old this kid is
I'd like to see you guess okay can I
just quickly
if I may
no okay that's fine phallic plants yeah
what's this phallic plant Southern Pit
Boss feels like it should be like a
grinder category
you know twink bear
otters Southern Pit Boss
it's just it's just I drop your trousers
yeah yeah just the meat smoker guy but
you like him yeah
I smoke two kinds of meat [__] and Bull
like a buffalo chicken sandwich
we got some chicken breasts cut into
sandwich slices
got it sitting in some egg and
buttermilk mixture to help get that
coating though this is a 45 year old 13
year old right wanna wash your hands it
won't work on our coat it won't take off
so it's loud he's got a baby face yeah
but he looks to be about six and a half
feet tall down what ew what baby don't
start
she's got a baby face ew gross no sorry
yeah he does have
a child's appearance but he must be six
and a half feet tall yeah well and his
mannerisms and his Personality yeah all
right it's 52 years old yeah yeah today
we're cooking down some real nice
buffalo style chicken do you know his
age I have no idea
he looks like one of those
dogs like dogs that are super big but
like yeah young yeah you know what I
mean yeah their paws are gigantic you're
like oh that bug's gonna be a beast yeah
big was that big barbecue with Jake
he's a paramedic so he's
he's old enough to be a paramedic
there's gonna be 18.
18 19. how many 18 year old paramedics
do you know uh one of my boys that I
went to high school with with paramedic
straight out of high school really yeah
straight up
wow yeah so these like
damn that's crazy
it oh man I was about to kid Cuddy this
[__] why
two of my boys are paramedics
the [__] they used to tell us
oh my god dude just be like a Wednesday
and they're like yeah we just picked up
some guy who tried to
self-harm oh [__] like that yeah oh my
God yeah dark yeah sorry
and he's [__] 18 years old yeah yeah
like 1920 just like ingesting crazy
trauma that's wild but yeah barbecue is
awesome I love [__] smoked meat
I'm sorry
um yeah so let's keep watching that I
wanted this man has the most soothing
soothing voice
dude I gotta commend you for getting
online and being like
actually no he's probably legal so
you're fine yeah exactly yeah he's a
paramedic dude yeah that's true
burn ends but didn't want to spend burn
in money today we're gonna make some
poor man's burn in
start off with some smoked sausage right
do however much you want to do we're
just doing one link today we're gonna
hit him with a little mustard mustard
mustard rub that together on there like
a binder we'll use some kind of brown
sugar and some baby Jake's Savory Sal
we're going in there for about two hours
and we'll come back and check on oh my
God okay so we got our four man's
burn-ins off the smoker we'll add a
little bit more both of our rugs it's
good [__] right yep are you are we
waiting to see the finished product yeah
okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go ahead
now let me tell you something
this this guy
should he have children
born from himself and another
and he raises them to be some big ass
kids oh yeah they're gonna be eating
right oh yeah I mean big
I mean big like they're probably gonna
be taller than him because you're gonna
be getting fed crazy nutrients from day
one
hey man you old enough to chew yeah
feeding a baby burnt ends yeah
babe his teeth came in how many teeth we
got two burnt ends
we need to stop playing with your burnt
ends burnt ends meet them yeah
it's got like burnt like charcoal stains
on his forehead from the burnt ends yeah
nah man Big Jake
he's not he's not I
I would venture to say his child might
just be Jake too
[Laughter]
Jake Jr yeah Jake too just hi Junior I
think Jake too yeah you grew up in the
Xbox era yeah he might just view things
a bit different well you know Elon got
away with numbers in the name so I
figured why not Jake why don't more
people do that
not the second two just two Jake two
I've met a kid named seven
like the number yes no I'm saying like
spelled with the number or spelled out
seven in English I think it was spelled
in English if I see what you're saying
yeah yeah birth certificate seven that's
hard as hell yeah that's what you're
saying number seven
yeah on your birth certificate yeah name
the number seven yeah yeah three lines
seven yeah College Essex yeah yeah
if you have a kid you have to name him
seven now no I want to name him Cody too
okay all right all right all right yeah
well what about Cody the sequel
damn how [__] would that be his middle
name is the sequel It's hard as [__] you
can't not become like a pro wrestler
cool come down here or a software
engineer yeah it's either one of the two
yeah no I think wrestler man yeah
are there are there really tall people
in your family like
um
no not really maybe he just like gets
like a recessive trait there isn't
Kelsey's family hmm
maybe he gets like a a two generations
back recessive trait and he's a beast
yeah yeah he's like he lives up to the
name yeah the sequel the sequel yeah
he's like he's better than you in every
way yeah exactly yeah everything tall
hung yeah
oh yeah I mean that one yeah
won't be hard to beat me in that regard
you know I took a pause there because I
realized that was mean it's all way
bigger dick than you uh cooler
funnier I'll ask her that for him yeah
you know his first time eating in and
out let's get his opinion hi everybody
audition videos while I was in Vegas
yeah we're gonna try In and Out Burger
I've never had In and Out Burger before
but today I got a single Patty Burger
side order of fry let's go what are we
thinking
that's the review hard as hell
just
okay
what do we think it's over all the fries
they're pretty bland not that great they
can use some more salt a little more
time with fryer
this burger it's pretty good
and that's where it's at
I want this dude as my grandpa yeah